y
[Música]
i
en eeuu la polémica ley antiaborto que
aprobó el estado de texas puede acabar
impulsando a otros estados a dar luz
verde a esta normativa todo ello después
de la decisión del tribunal supremo de
no bloquear esta ley el texto
legislativo que ya ha entrado en vigor o
beta el aborto a las seis semanas de
gestación cuando se puede detectar el
latido del corazón del feto pero en la
mayoría de los casos ni en las mujeres
saben que están embarazadas la ley
además ni siquiera contempla excepciones
en caso de incesto o violación lo más
controversial es que con esta nueva
normativa cualquiera puede presentar una
demanda contra alguien por haber ayudado
en un aborto incluso por llevar a una
mujer al hospital en estados como
arkansas dakota del sur y aquí en
florida sus gobernadores ya han
expresado interés por esta legislación y
podrían presentarla muy pronto en sus
respectivas cámaras aunque ya han dicho
que están analizando la a fondo pero no
son los únicos en carolina del sur
kentucky louisiana oklahoma y ohio
también podrían seguir con esa misma
línea
a pocos días de su instalación la
asamblea legislativa de mayoría
oficialista archivo al menos 300
iniciativas y proyectos de ley
incluyendo la controvertida reforma al
código penal para despenalizar el aborto
al igual que otras iniciativas como la
ley de identidad para las personas trans
esta propuesta de las organizaciones
feministas ha sido catalogada de
obsoleta por la nueva legislatura
actualmente el país tiene una de las
leyes antiaborto más escritas del mundo
por una prohibición total del aborto y
penas de hasta 30 años de cárcel la
propuesta de reforma presentada en 2016
y desechada por los legisladores busca
valorar la despenalización cuando la
vida de la mujer está en riesgo así como
en casos de violación o cuando el feto
presente complicaciones que han inviable
la vida fuera del útero en el salvador
más de 200 mujeres han sido procesadas
por aborto u homicidio agravado en los
últimos 20 años debido a complicaciones
en su embarazo sin embargo la nueva
legislatura no ha reaccionado a los
cuestionamientos de las organizaciones
feministas que catalogan esta decisión
como un retroceso y una violación a los
derechos humanos de las mujeres
el aborto es un tema de debate legal ni
moral en china aquí son habituales los
anuncios de clínicas abortistas en la
tele o que los padres se los recomienden
a sus hijas solteras hay unos 9 millones
de abortos anuales y el porcentaje entre
las mujeres que se sometieron a él es
más del doble que en eeuu china carece
de la tradición cristiana que se opone a
él en las sociedades occidentales aquí
siempre ha imperado más el pragmatismo
el partido comunista se opuso a él
cuando llegó al poder a mediados del
siglo pasado porque faltaba gente y lo
estimuló décadas después porque sobraba
fueron los años de la política del hijo
único que estimuló los abortos
selectivos por la preferencia por el
varón en las sociedades rurales y eso
explica que hoy hay a 30 millones más de
hombres que de mujeres la práctica está
prohibida hasta muy penada y además hay
varias provincias que han aprobado
restricciones al aborto más allá de la
14ª semanarios cuando es más fácil
distinguir el sexo del feto
[Música]